all right Tulsa is one of the cities of
existing the calls to defund the police
but elsewhere in the country the radical
left is getting exactly what it wants
and cops are walking off the job the
Atlanta Police Department reported a
higher than usual number of call-outs in
other words a walkout and NYPD officers
are being encouraged apparently to call
in sick on the 4th of July that would be
known as the blue flu and it is
spreading to other cities as well police
in Philadelphia Louisville and tell a
Hasse are also considering walking out
and joining me now is a woman who has
perhaps the best perspective of what the
police are facing and have been facing
Heather McDonald Manhattan Institute
Fellow and author of the aptly named the
war on cops
Heather welcome aboard thanks for
joining me thanks for having me on Tammy
I appreciate it now look we're seeing an
unusual dynamic in a lot of ways of
course the the mood of the police across
the country is down for some
understandable reasons what is it going
to take for Democrat mayors and city
officials because I think in general
Democrats do care about their cities
they care about the lives of people we
heard that in that least call from
Chicago what is it going to take for
people to stand up for the police
officers which provide social cohesion
in every city whether it be blue or red
well I think you're being a little too
generous it took about three decades of
increasing crime in New York City for
voters to throw out the existing
Democratic political structure there and
bring in a mayor that actually did care
about the lives the thousands of lives
that were being lost in the black
communities that turns out ideology is a
lot more powerful than even a mayor's
interest in being reelected what's
happening to the police in this country
Tammy is tragic and outrageous they're
living under the effects of a lie all of
them are being painted as racist
systemically racist the reality is we
don't have a policing problem in this
country we have a crime problem the
police are in the neighborhoods that
they are because that's where people are
being victimized that's where the
drive-by shooting
occurring that's where the children are
being shot in their homes in their
backyards
the police don't wish that reality is
forced upon them the rest of the country
turns its eyes away from them
the cops are understandably and
incredibly demoralized no other
profession lives under the burden of
this hatred and what they're
experiencing the streets now when they
try to make an arrest people are
interfering they're throwing things at
them they're cursing at them
it is completely understandable that
they're backing off because they're
being told that it is racist to try to
protect lives in minority communities
it's enough to change but but one of the
problems I have to say Heather one of
the problems is and I love the police
I'm in a law-and-order kind of gal but
when you do retreat of course the
communities that are hurt first are
minority communities you've got you know
they're calling the police as much as
anyone else is they're reliant they
don't have money for private security
they don't have gated communities if you
will and so that concerns me a little
but it really is an attack and you noted
New York New York it's a single-party
city like Los Angeles has been to some
degree certainly Chicago is a disaster
because it has been a single-party City
I think for 140 years isn't this really
about leadership and and the messaging
it sends to the community about the
police and and if leadership doesn't
respect the police why should the people
respect them it's absolutely about
leadership these leaders can ask their
police chiefs tell me the reality of
crime they can be out there in front
saying the police are not racist we need
the police our communities need the
police instead the leaders are pandering
to the most radical elements in their
cities and they are selling out those
thousands of law-abiding residents of
minority communities so what it's going
to take I don't know Tammy and it is a
dilemma but it is as I say what are the
cops supposed to do because they are
terrified that they're going to face
another rush to justice like we've seen
in Atlanta completely unjustified murder
charges they again they're experiencing
from a small segment of the community
extraordinary
contempt they worry now about more
shootings i-i've I'm terrified myself
that we're gonna see a lot more attacks
on cops right and so yes they do back
off because the message that they're
getting most unequivocally from the
media is you're racist to be in my
northern community Heather thank you and
that's one of the differences is what
media is perpetuating versus what
communities need to do into coming
together for those other members of
their community who happen to be police
officers Heather thank you very much for
joining me tonight I appreciate it